asake Brewery and the pride of the
community has returned to the town of
Nami in Japan's Fukushima prefecture
Swept Away by the 2011 tsunami it has
since been rebuilt by owner Daisuke
Suzuki at a new site
for centuries my ancestors had worked to
create the flavor of the sake to suit
the taste of fish after opening the
brewery next to the fishing port of
ukedo the tradition is also helping to
restore a sense of pride in a fishing
Community devastated by the tsunami and
the nuclear meltdown
he produces sake that tastes good with
Fish And encourages fishermen to
continue fishing people in the town can
want to drink it and support fishermen
as well Japan released its first batch
of Wastewater from the Fukushima daiichi
nuclear power plant in August and is
releasing a second batch starting on
Thursday
the government has been working hard to
convince people that Japanese seafood is
safe
we have been monitoring Marine Products
since the first release of treated water
and they are below the limit so the
safety is confirmed many countries
understand that reaction around the
region has been mixed here in South
Korea the government says it will
conduct thorough tests
stick and imported Seafood it is neither
opposed nor approved Japan's Wastewater
release but it has maintained a ban on
Seafood products from areas around
Fukushima China Russia and some Pacific
island nations have criticized the move
Beijing has banned all Seafood from
Japan and Moscow has said it may do the
same
perspective concerns Japan has failed to
properly respond to these issues and to
guarantee the absence of threats
including a long-term one and in July
the UN nuclear Watchdog said the release
of treated Wastewater was safe but that
hasn't been enough to allay safety
concerns for some
Florence Louis Al Jazeera Seoul
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera